Shantay is with us in Atlanta
hi Shantae how are you Shantay good
thank you so much for taking my call
sure what's up okay so fuzzy and I are
on two separate baby steps I got started
listening to your keeping all of your
books I know let's see what happened was
we are newlyweds we've been married for
three months now so once you're married
you're not on separate baby steps as a
family you're on one or the other you
combine your finances when you're
married yeah and that's what we're
trying to do now I didn't take the 20
minutes yeah thing is we have so many
things that automatically dropped it out
of our account that we're trying to get
to the point that we are having it all
in one but it's just I don't know okay
let's not let stop us saying okay I'm
talking about philosophically and
relationally making a list of all the
debts that we have and all the money
that we have even if they're in two
separate checking accounts for right now
we can still make a list and start
calling it we instead because when you
get married it's French it's oui oui the
work that the preacher does not saying
now you're a joint venture and so you
really really need to combine your stuff
so how much debt did he bring to the
marriage well a lot of it was coming
from ours when it comes to like the
things that we cost the cost for the
wedding and things like that but handled
his own he has about nine thousand and
student loans because all right you are
good
how much do you have it's mostly
combined or when they comes to the
credit card debt so us together it's
about thirty nine thousand we paid off
about five thousand so far good and the
money did you have that you brought
separate from that of the marriage mmm
it's probably less than about three
thousand okay so all we do is just add
all of that up and put it on one sheet
your own separate baby steps by the way
even if you were doing it separately you
both have debt you're both in baby step
two
okay yeah I think that I think is that
he's never really saved that money on
his own so he was more excited about
getting to that thousand dollars
but oh okay okay so you're eligible I
already have a thousand put aside I felt
like well maybe we're both already on
two but no no I don't have one
$1,000 savings between the two of you
that we have and now you're on baby step
two and then we are going to list all of
our debts smallest to largest credit
cards student loans that he brought the
$3,000 that you brought we're going to
list all of these things smallest to
largest we're going to pay minimum
payments on all of them except the
smallest one and we are going to combine
our income and attack the smallest one
as fast as possible
moving the automatic withdrawals to one
account is a step that if that takes a
little while that's fine but you can
combine your budgets your goals and your
process tonight
Yeah right Dave does that make sense you
really can yeah you really can't it's
because it's a mechanical thing it's not
a thing where you have to wait until you
know statefarm doesn't draft the
insurance from your account he grabs it
from you know whichever account it may
take a month to move all that stuff
around that's fine but but you still
have an income he still has an income we
list them together at the top of the
page then we have rent and food and
lights that we are paying and then we
have the debt snowball that we are
attacking and we start walking right
down through it and so what do you make
a year about 35,000 what does he make a
year
about 40,000 great okay so you got an
$80,000 household income how old are you
- I am 34 he's 36 awesome very cool well
you guys are in good place it's just
what's going to happen is this is going
to feel like you know mowing the grass
in the front yard you're going to make
you're going to see progress so quickly
that you're going to go wow this is cool
I can see it because I've done this for
so long that when you guys combine this
stuff tonight and you really get through
every dollar budget out and really put
it all together you're gonna you're
gonna look down you're going
wait a minute that thousand-dollar extra
that we got over here let's just throw
that on that smaller step oh wait a
minute I was gone now and you're just
gonna start going boom it's going to
start happening and you're gonna start
chopping up credit cards and it's going
to be a party yes that sound oh and I
want you guys I'm going to give you a
wedding gift a little bit late I want
you to go through Financial Peace
University have y'all been through yet
no we haven't and you don't spend a
little hi out that would be amazing the
only thing he's apprehensive about being
around other people to share a story and
to talk about debt and things he'll just
just tell the class you're apprehensive
about it and don't share it go in there
and learn and listen to other people's
stories and once you get comfortable
you'll probably end up sharing it but
it's not like we force you to get tell
your people your underwear size or
something okay all right that sounds
good let me just tell you let me tell
you what's gonna happen the very first
night you're going to find people that
are dumber than you because there's
always somebody in the classes then
something's more Super than you've done
so you're starting with a half my stoop
is not even as big as you're stupid I
can talk about it but you don't have to
it's not required
hold on I'll give you the class as my
gift as long as both of you promise to
attend it's my gift to you and you have
to promise to send some young couple
when they first get married that need to
combine their finances someday in the
future when you're rich you got to pay
it forward okay if you're going to be
rich if you do what I teach you to do
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]